oh my hands are washed I promise come on
okay i man wait wait wait [ __ ] I wanna
link you'll mess the whole team but that
doesn't mean I am
okay I'm so angry what
oh I'm joy night I know I see you hey
Jack oh you came Jack what do you do
when you your hands together oh I'm
being a perv Jack deal with it exit no
you're an evil zambie now we won't be
nice touching your butt face pic ditch
my face Peter lap your face chicken eyes
left to tickle your nose stop touching
me yeah my a my my hydras are kind of
not coordinated believe me neither
oh stop it tickle tickle tickle
load this video let's see yes video
loading oh yeah video section this is so
is the sound plane yes it is
gonna eat your ass on a sandwich girl
this is so weird
this week a new today's deception this
is video ception
we should put on some content alright
some Harry Potter music in the
background while we do this so nice dad
cha-cha Kapoor Avada Kedavra oh god what
happened
you died cuz you're Voldemort so what
did you do you sat down what did you do
oh oh god you used to spell on me to sit
down wait wait here we can we can be
fancy that my head spins Exorcist
Exorcist really creepy dude I'm too
short there we go yeah hey Ryan
hey your head spins now Oh does it it
doesn't fit me you spin my head right
round right
when I and you go down when you go down
oh Jesus me possess folly might what
spell did you stop it stop bad how could
you get up it fixes it my booger in your
nose it you beaucoup light of my nose
I am Voldemort now to bless your nips
that's your peen don't say what it's
like that please I'm gonna have to
censor this video now let's speed it
dude oh god someone else doing Oh God
oh no four turns answer ten we're normal
uh okay okay okay oh yeah comes Oh what
they did they do what did they do okay
she say she didn't pretend it I see us
they see ice oh um no don't I don't have
my temper him and how do I talk again
I'm good why did you nice I am very oh
jeez Nixon what the [ __ ]
Maisie I like your haircut where did you
get it
I like your burr ro Carmen's and let's
touch our boy his boogers come here kami
come here to me come here so easy come
closer come closer come closer I hope he
doesn't know who we are I hope he does
Susie because otherwise he'd be really
weirded out right now oh oh nice pin
there you got an inch I didn't even
enter the theater that time I just did
it from the menu the joint menu oh you
know that's the first time that actually
works yeah so look at me I'm holding my
lights ever do you see this what are you
doing to yourself jack what am i doing I
don't know my hands are weird
look at this yeah am i doing me no yeah
you are let's fight like this
da-da-da-da-da-da da-da-da-da-da-da how
do you movie me ha ha ha dear Baltimore
let me touch your face dude oh dude
you're not ugly Ron
you have a beautiful inside I always
hated Harry but I loved you Ron a bit oh
stop it
oh hello that's one way to hug you come
here come here come here uh uh I got as
close as I'll ever get to a PewDiePie
home I feel sad I would make life and
wait I'm gonna sit down next to you this
is gonna be amazing
you're not gonna want to sit down for
long though it just works is it is it a
dance things work Oh for the love of
yeah yeah uh what an intimate moment I'm
holding my arm around you I can't put it
around you I said yeah I can't quite
lady there there we go Harry
there we go I reach around house if it
was I you got a son horn what what up
corn whoa whoa slide okay are you ready
wait am I afraid yeah yeah this is what
I was like in the club yeah yeah use
your sexy dance Oh am i doing this I
don't know but your head is by my head
oh god what happened
oh that's now there's a power of
darude-sandstorm
wait what is this game called again this
no no wait this song what is it some
kind or are you sure yeah my arm is
stuck like my hand keeps [ __ ] moving
alright
change change to like a karaoke or
whatever or is something else I don't
know I don't know how do we what Oh
your breasts are really growing quite
nicely there Jeff thank you I had
surgery last week I'm just checking for
lumps or any our Ordinaries is standard
don't worry about it it's gotta be safe
whoa hello Jack what are you doing I
don't know what's going on Rick I don't
know but my lights safer
what's happening you're just standing a
position to me my my lights every is
going everywhere
Oh control your lightsaber young I'm
trying well guarded me it disappeared
I vote put a pie for president because
there will be free breakfast
oh no charge get off the podium no but
you know I have the right to speak don't
ever worked the best there is no one
here but I need to say myself ok ok I'll
sit down you give your speech
honey why I should vote for you um there
will be no you gotta be we're prepared
for hecklers oh don't be mean you there
sir oh yeah they all do the either fist
I have a question no no wait afterwards
until I finished all right they always
do this with their Fitz they have one
hand here and then they do it ok yeah so
pudy pie is the best youtuber because he
makes funny jokes and funny voices hi
you sir stop you there stop it
hi sorry I saw who it was yeah there's
no one else here who was that
woo oh yeah ok continue thank you
finally someone with some respect here
jacksepticeye copy one of my videos you
should all go and hate on him where
where is that jacksepticeye how [ __ ]
dare he Jack Jack in the building he is
hiding somewhere I'm sure
wait my shirt says Jack oh don't know
where that's probably just a bug in the
system ok ok and then I also have this
laser tracking device that will beep
once it goes over a jack and there peep
I don't think it's fine beep I don't why
I'm going with expect quite beep it's
it's totally beeping right now this is
so where it's beep it's the beeping is
getting louder where is that beeping
coming fried don't know beep beep beep
me beep r2d2 must be here you're right
yes II died I don't are you trying to
kill me
you're Voldemort stop it that was Jack
that man was dead
welcome to your orchard Edith was here
it was good great impression all right
let me see so see you here all right um
oh there's a stick here all right yeah
um I mean that's not a stick well this
is tater give me water
okay demand water this song is a problem
this man had a hit in the 90s why is it
irrelevant
his name is darude we need to target him
and get him out of here
yeah he's cherished don't do that with
your head please it's very disturbing
thank you he's a terrorist confirmed
terrorist conspiracy it makes me very
upset uncle my head swings when I'm
upset or to teach you hey aren't you
were you peeping before I think that's a
you know oh it's up tonight okay
where will it terrific 1800 there's a
couch here touch that you if cleans okay
bo I Swedish guy an Irish guy walk into
a cinema the Irish guy says long face Oh
what did you if accordions hilarious
kidding are my hands in here hope your
hand is going through your face I think
yes that is impressive whatever it is
you're doing I can't see anything I'm
sorry I can't kill you're gonna have to
respawn like the old-fashioned way hey
Jack am i here come on come here
I'm coming come I'm here come here hi ah
let's go to the bathroom why'd you oh my
god can you sit down on the toilets
I hope so baby tell me you yeah please
tell me what is this what really sit
down in the urine
no this no you got it send one urinal
away from each other oh my god I think
you can't yes you can sit on the toilets
come in here
Jack hi what are you doing
get out what are you doing I'm taking
the shame
help me off the toilet he'll help help
I'm stuck I'm Jack it's happy the sound
just made a sound oh my god no no my
hands are washed I promise
come on okay i man wait wait wait ah
[ __ ] I wipe our ass I can see your teeth
eyes oh my god oh my god what has been
seen okay wait we learn to lock the door
for the love of God